it doesn't look like you're using
anything very drying cuz I don't see any
dry skin you girl say
voice are you wearing makeup right now
I'm not oh my God and you have amazing
skin but I can tell you have a little
bit of allergies no no no allergies no
so you're from Miami unfortunately
you're going to probably have a little
bit more sun damage on your skin and I
just see a few clogged pores um on the
forehead it's probably from like hair
stuff from Maids called pade acne I
caught a hint of some hyperpigmentation
across your nose here it's not due to
allergies I hope it ain't dirt no I
don't think your skin probably gives you
many problems I think that you have a
simple skincare routine give it to me
tell me reveal my skincare routine is it
elaborate no it's not actually I don't
do anything will wash my face with soap
I haven't found the right thing and if I
do